[Música]
eu quero começar compartilhando três
cenas reais de homens e suas prisões
a primeira cena ano passado estava
conversando com um grande diretor de uma
empresa de engenharia e ele estava me
dizendo que gostaria de conversar de
maneira mais aberta e carinhosa com a
própria esposa e os filhos
só que ele não tinha a menor ideia como
segunda cena estava conversando com um
amigo
trinta e poucos anos bonito bem sucedido
saudável
lá pelas tantas ele falou comigo que
estava com um problema de brucha era
bruxa um outra vez era bruxa bastante
dava para sentir vergonha dele quando eu
falei que eu já tinha passado por isso e
sugerir e procurar um psicólogo
especializado em sexualidade masculina
estava presente o alívio
ele vendeu tinha uma maneira de resolver
aquilo
cena 3 o parceiro de uma grande amiga
perdeu emprego eles moravam juntos
então no começo foram só alguns ajustes
financeiros e logística passou algumas
semanas ele passou a sair - com os
amigos
depois de alguns meses ele não atendia
as ligações dos amigos ele estava a ver
com muita vergonha de estar desempregado
ele passou mais de um ano sem aceitar
ajuda de ninguém até reconhecer que
estava em depressão finalmente tem apoio
e consegui atravessar esse contexto eu
começo com histórias ao invés de dados
de pesquisa porque a gente não precisa
de pesquisa para saber que os homens
estão mal
é só olhar para o lado e escutar o que
todas essas histórias têm em comum o
silêncio homens que não faz
seja por medo ou insegurança por não
saber a quem procurar
às vezes com a desculpa de que eles não
querem levar o problema para outra
pessoa
mas quando você fica em silêncio é o
caminho mais rápido para fazer
justamente quem você ama sofrer junto os
homens vivem prisões que eles mesmos
ajudam a sustentar isso me lembra da
única vez em que me perguntaram porque o
papo de homem foi criado
já me perguntaram inúmeras vezes como
mas só uma vez porque a resposta é
simples solidão solidão masculina que
afeta tanto os homens é que a gente
começa a construir muito cedo quando
tinha 10 anos uma professora pediu para
fazer um desenho de como ela seria aos
30 e eu lembro desse desenho porque eu
teria um metro e oitenta 80 quilos uma
esposa dois filhos e um milhão de reais
na conta
corta quando tinha 18 anos era feio
magrelo cheio de espinhas morria de medo
de apanhar
eu lembro daquela entrevista que o
romário deu na época dizendo que dava 10
em tirar de dentro e não conseguia dar
um beijo na boca nem transar
eu lembro que nessa época eu sentia
muita raiva culpa e angústia
eu não tinha com quem falar sobre isso e
eu não acho que eu sofria pelo homem que
eu era eu acho que eu sofria porque eu
não me achava homem o suficiente
e de onde vem isso como essa idéia se
constrói de alguma maneira que eu fui
escutado de mídia escola família na rua
minha própria personalidade minhas
próprias escolhas me fizeram acreditar
que eu não era homem suficiente e tem
outras coisas que a gente vai escutando
por aí que todo homem escuta que gruda
seja homem vai ser frouxo de mulherzinha
aguenta o tranco deixa de ser
e o pior é que quando a gente escuta uma
coisa como deixa de ser vem junto
à homofobia orientação sexual não torna
ninguém - homem
a única coisa que um comentário desse
mostra é o pânico que a masculinidade
tem de ser percebida como - homem e esse
medo está na base de um conceito chamado
de mendonça ex
traduzindo a caixa do homem a
representação visual desse conceito é um
quadrado dentro de si quadrado
a gente tem tudo que é usualmente
esperado dos homens se forte e dominador
viril potente sempre tem um plano fora
do quadrado
tudo o que não é esperado fraco
hesitante pouco ambicioso sensível
demais chorão mulher sim é gay
isso a gente nota
o que a gente vê é que muitos dos
comportamentos não esperados são
características associadas ao feminino
então no centro da construção da
identidade masculina usual
a gente tem o medo do feminino
isso leva alguns comportamentos bem
ruins obsessividade com sucesso poderá
competição fechamento emocional
emocionalidade restrita entre os
próprios homens se vai fazer carinho e
gorila a conflitos entre relações de
trabalho família pra ver um homem que
nunca viveu isso em um dos nomes que dá
para todo esse contexto que eu estou
desenhando é masculinidade tóxica a
masculinidade tóxica se expressa com um
torcedor tá com uma barra de ferro e
bate na cabeça do outro até não sobrar
nada porque ele está usando uma camiseta
de cor diferente
a masculinidade tóxica é quando o homem
acha que pode controlar o que é parceira
veste com quem ela fala com que ela anda
e até o que ela pensa
é também quando jovem devem todas as
festas de faculdade até cair porque é
bonita sob controle até o dia em que ele
veio um alcoólatra e destrói a própria
família a reconhecer esse contexto
reconhecer todos os muitos privilégios
do masculino e as privações reconhecer
essa complexidade é o primeiro passo
para a mudança
esse papo de que os homens são simples
as mulheres são complicadas
é puro mito mas aí alguém pode perguntar
na platéia
tá mas quem disse que os homens querem
se transformar
ele está no poder tanto no bem bom eles
não querem na verdade não é bem assim
ano passado a gente fez uma pesquisa
nacional que a onu mulheres
a gente escutou mais de 20 mil pessoas
em todo o brasil
a gente encontrou alguns dados bem
interessantes
sessenta e sete por cento dos homens
brasileiros gostariam de falar sobre
seus maiores medos e dúvidas com os
melhores amigos mas não fazem isso
quarenta e cinco por cento dos homens
gostariam de se expressar de modo mais
aberto e carinhoso e igual o diretor do
começo da minha fala mas eles não sabem
como 81 por cento dos homens gostariam
de cuidar melhor da própria saúde
não à toa os amigos em sete anos a menos
do que as mulheres no brasil a gente tem
um sistema carcerário cuja população é
composta em 95% por homens
mais de 90% dos homicídios são entre
homens
eles citam quatro vezes mais do que as
mulheres
e nada disso é para vitimizar
ao comparar sofrimento é pra gente olhar
um pouco mais clareza para a situação
será que os homens nascem para ser
assassinos
eu tendo a pensar que gênero no poder
não conta a história toda
eu interpreto masculino hoje como um
gênero de extremos porque ao mesmo tempo
que tem maioria dos líderes de negócios
e líderes políticos lota as prisões e os
cemitérios porque vivem de maneira auto
destrutiva
os homens consomem álcool como malucos
drogas se matam com o carro faca arma de
fogo
matam violentam estuprar mulheres todos
os dias
isso não pode seguir assim e há maneiras
de mudar a nossa pesquisa não se
concentrou apenas em entender o tamanho
do problema a gente buscou mapear como a
transformação pode acontecer ea gente
identificou sete grandes gatilhos de
transformação dos homens baseados em
iniciativas que já existem
de norte a sul do brasil anos só não são
conhecidas
então está falando de gatilhos como
afeto paternidade exposição ao
sofrimento das mulheres busca por vida
mais satisfatória acesso a espaços
seguros e de acolhimento momentos de
ruptura e crise e espiritualidade
infelizmente inúmeros homens só se abrem
para a mudança quando no fundo do poço
na crise mas há outras maneiras de fazer
isso eu quero contar alguns desses
exemplos
a lei maria da penha determina que todo
homem condenado deve ser encaminhado por
um processo de reabilitação e o nome
desse processo é grupo reflexivo nesse
grupo uma série de outros homens aqui
também foram condenados vão passar por
uma série de encontros e vivências com
um psicólogo facilitador e basicamente o
que vai se dar lhe é que eles vão
refletir sobre o que é masculinidade
sobre o que é ser homem e sobre como é
que se constrói um relacionamento
amoroso e saudável com a sua parceira ou
seu parceiro aqui no maranhão a taxa de
reincidência é de 75% para os agressores
ou seja três em cada quatro homens que
agridem vamos fazer isso de novo
o instituto patrícia galvão fez uma
pesquisa com os homens que passam pelos
grupos reflexivos e eles notaram que a
reincidência cai para até 5 por cento ou
seja a gente está falando de uma
iniciativa potencialmente 15 vezes mais
eficaz porque isso acontece mais ainda é
mal visto
pesquisas apontam que mais da metade da
população acha que a punição é a maneira
mais eficaz de lidar com o homem
agressor
a punição muitas vezes é um meio
necessário para interromper ciclos de
violência e evitar tragédias mas ela
sozinha não vai conseguir operar
transformação que a gente precisa e tem
outras iniciativas maravilhosas
acontecendo em grupos de homens em
recife que se reúnem na laje do bar para
discutir saúde masculina com um médico
porque na loja do bairro porque é onde
eles já vão a gente não precisa levar
todo mundo para uma sala chata e fria em
torneios de futebol que fazem
conscientização de gênero aumento da
licença paternidade para os jovens
voltarem para casa e cuidar dos filhos
rodas de conversa com adolescentes em
escolas que usam os textos e vídeos que
eles já lêem assistem na web ea própria
pesquisa que a gente fez o que
desembocou em um documentário que está
público pra todo mundo assistir no
youtube da onu mulheres
o documentário se chama precisamos falar
com os homens
uma jornada pela igualdade de gênero são
só algumas das iniciativas pessoal
porque criticar masculinidade
oxi é completamente diferente de crítica
ao masculino os homens no masculino é
amplo e rico maravilhoso assim como
feminino
eu queria tomar a liberdade de caminhar
para o final da minha fala lendo um e
mail que a gente recebeu semana passada
de um policial
a gente escreveu sobre a crise dos
policiais no espírito santo imagino que
todo mundo acompanhou quando essa crise
acabou
os policiais em massa foram procurar
atendimento psicológico no hospital
psicológico da pm sabe o que aconteceu
eles foram ridicularizados com falas
como deixa de ser frouxo agora aguenta o
tranco virou mocinha
a gente fez um texto denunciando essa
situação
a gente recebeu um e mail que é assim
boa tarde gostaria neste primeiro
momento de agradecer a todos da página
que contribuem diariamente para o meu
crescimento
confesso que quando comecei a acompanhar
o papo de homem eu era metida
reacionário o machista e bastante babaca
muito se passou de lá pra cá tive
auxílio de minha irmã e minha esposa
duas mulheres que ajudaram a transformar
muito obrigado a transformação acontece
pessoal
a gente recebe meio assim toda semana e
quase sempre são de pessoas que
acompanham a gente anos isso conta de
outra coisa muito importante esse
processo toma tempo paciência
acolhimento continuidade
por isso eu quero terminar com um
convite para todos os homens que estão
aqui e todos os homens que vão assistir
esse vídeo que a gente possa criar e
sustentar espaços de transformação para
o masculino são os espaços poder são os
espaços de mudança escuta espaços
físicos
espaços digitais espaços de encontro
pode ser junto com que a gente já faz
pode ser um churrasco no futebol
o encontro dos amigos só que em vez de
levar a couraça ea máscara ea coisa de
macho
você vai levar o coração aberto -
julgamento
a abertura os homens podem e querem se
transformar
mas eles não vão conseguir fazer
sozinhos
vamos juntos obrigado
[Aplausos]